yeah I don't know if YouTube has done
that uh I don't know I wouldn't credit
YouTube with changing people's tastes in
comedy I mean I think that like we
always laugh because we feel like we
work pretty hard on you know writing and
shooting stuff and then we'll put stuff
out there and then sure enough you know
there'll be a 30-second clip of a cat
farting and that'll get 50 billion hits
you know it's like why don't we just
shoot cats farting you know that's
easier I don't have to write it so I
don't know if YouTube is raising the bar
for comedy I feel like that's a lot of
you know just people liking the see that
there on the internet and just sort of
fishing trolling for anything but
specifically I do feel like you know
some of these other sites like like
Funny or Die and college humor I think
are really creating a forum for people
and creating like an audience for people
more importantly and yeah it's like I
mean I think what the internet is also
doing is it's just it's definitely
obviously shortening shortening people's
attention span so for us that's always
like something to keep in mind you know
because no one's going to I got news for
you to on this interview no one's going
to watch this fucking long answer that I
just gave you everything has to be like
really short
you